my colleague Pat Mooney who's after much
longer now than I have reckons that it
takes roughly a human generation to
understand the impacts of our technology
and I think he's probably being a bit
short on that I think it's something
more like a human lifetime so I'm not
really expecting we're going to get a
very clear reading on synthetic biology
tonight or anytime soon but I am gonna
argue that that lag between deploying
our technologies and understanding our
technologies is a good reason why we
should be supplementing the art of the
long view with that policy of the long
path by which I mean the deliberate
careful path of precaution and I note
that I've been billed as a historian
tonight and that's a big shoes to fill
and especially as I bumped off most my
history degree doing direct action but
I'm gonna try and not disappoint and to
bring at least a few lessons from
history particularly lessons from the
closest parallel that I can find which
is the synthetic chemical industry and
apart from the name and the fact that
DNA synthesis is a chemistry technique
and what these two two fields share is
they're both about building synthesizing
nature from standard molecular parts and
indeed the early chemists believed that
they could understand nature better by
building it just as drew does and but I
think the parallel that we're looking at
right now with synthetic biology is the
mid 19th century when the synthetic
chemists began to commercialize their
field I just want to quickly show you
how parallel those two moments are so if
you go out to 1856 this was the time
when a teenager in East London called
William Henry Perkin who was supposed to
be synthesizing a anti-malarial drug
quitting ended up synthesizing a
synthetic dye moving and realizing this
was a red hot commercial prospect he
commercialized it and a bunch of French
and German and Swiss entrepreneurs the
sort of mid 19th century equivalents of
craig Venter or Vinod Khosla copied his
his business model and they they also
started producing synthetic dyes and on
the back of this synthetic dye industry
the modern chemical industry was born
well you zip forward 150 years and just
across the bay Jay Keasling is also
trying to synthesis
an anti-malarial compound this time
artemisinin using biology and he finds
out that he can synthesize gasoline he
sets up a biofuels business and people
like Vinod Khosla and craig Venter copy
their idea and before you know it you
have a booming synthetic life industry
and what's interesting is that this new
synthetic life industry is following
some of the same questions that the
synthetic chemists faced 150 years ago
so here's drew dealing with questions
about monopolies and I hope you don't
mind but I think they're very 19th
century view of monopolies that you have
in the middle of the 19th century you
had a booming open source movement and
they rollback of the patent movement the
patent laws that really allowed the
industry to take off within a very short
time however that itself had been rolled
back in the mid 1970s a bunch of German
companies lobbied for a strong patent
law they used that to build a very
strong monopoly which by 1925 was a G
Farben our fourth largest monopoly in
the world and since that time the
chemical industry has been a highly
concentrated and highly powerful
industry right through to now and if you
look at BASF which is one of those
original companies it's now the largest
chemical company it's also got a one and
a half billion dollar agreement with
Monsanto on GMO seeds and its position
itself at the head of the pack on
nanotechnology so we moved in that case
from monopoly to oligopoly and I think
we're going to see this exactly this
with synthetic biology that while
there's an attempt to build a commons
we're already seeing patents being
placed being written by people like
craig Venter and DuPont which are being
set to crowd out the commons and and
established a monopoly position there is
going to be a microbe soft of synthetic
biology and I salute Lee attempts to
kick against that but I think history is
on the side of craig Venter on this one
and drew is concerned about
militarization and rightly so there you
go back to the history of synthetic
chemistry back in the 1850s you have
people like Lionel Playfair a British
chemist saying that you could use
chemistry in the Crimean War for for
chemical weapons and this this caused a
real stir
we had at least two treaties trying to
ban chemical weapons but by the time the
first world war came around both the
Allies and the Germans were releasing
synthetic chlorine into the wind to try
and gas their opponents two decades
later IG Farben BASF again was was
supplying zyklon-b into the gas chambers
at Auschwitz now if you'd said to the
founders of BASF in the 1860s that their
facilities would be used to carry out
mass murder by their own government they
would have said that was an extreme and
improbable thing but the balance of
probability changed very quickly across
one human lifetime and I really do think
that it's a it's a mistake to think that
with synthetic biology where we already
have had agents built that can kill 50
million people as it did last last
century in the case of 1918 flu virus
that you can on the one hand restrain
the hostile uses of this technology and
on the other hand have a booming
industry that really is a fairy tale
that high-tech companies and high-tech
industries tell their population to try
and make them sleep better at night
I think if drew is serious about disarm
in the future you have to realize that
the existence of an industry and a
capacitor dust Realty means that they
will be commandeered in wartime by
States even states that you think he
trusts and the the way to disarm the
future is to disarm the large-scale
commercial production of anything using
synthetic biology and I think thirdly
looking back to the chemical industry
there's a clear lesson on economic
disruption you didn't have to wait for
soldiers to be killed on the battlefield
before they were already economic deaths
on the agricultural fields of turkey of
Mexico and of India that in fact those
who grew the natural dyes for the
dyestuffs industry saw the emergence of
a synthetic dye stuffs industry back in
the 1860s as a attack on first their
livelihoods and later their lives so in
1897 BASF and Baier had a synthetic
indigo dye blue which led to the
collapse of indigo growing in in Bengal
seventy-five percent of that area
planted to indigo collapsed
within a decade and then when famine
came along I was unemployed millions of
unemployed growers ended up dead and
those are just the sort of first
Canaries in the coal mine we've first
seen wave after wave of synthetic
products made by chemistry putting out
of work rubber tappers and cotton
producers and so forth but I think
synthetic biology is probably gonna
outdo all of that I mentioned already
Jay Keasling which is one of Drew's
colleagues and he has a project to
working with sanofi-aventis to replace
Artemisia which is usually grown by
thousands of small farmers in East
Africa and Southeast Asia and basically
to undercut them and put them out of
business um but it goes further when I
spoke with Jay Keasling recently he told
me that as far as he was concerned
synthetic biology meant that anything
that can be made from a plant can now be
made by a microbe in a vat think about
that anything that can be made from a
plant can now be made by a microbe in a
vat a statement like that if it's true
is the death knell for economies that
depend on plant derived commodities
whether that's tropical oils or fibers
or rubber or plant extracts for
pharmaceuticals and flavorings and so
forth what Jay Keasling statement means
is that for the customers of those
commodity dependent countries which are
usually the poorest countries in the
world they can now dangle the carrots or
the concern of synthetic biology and
then renegotiate costs they can
renegotiate trade deals they can switch
to microbial synthesis and leave whole
nations up in the air potentially to
spiral into hunger violence and unrest
so monopoly militarization massive
economic destruction three things that
we can already see from the beginning of
this and the last synthetic industry but
the real doozie with synthetic chemistry
came a full century later and that's in
1962 and Rachel Carson published Silent
Spring and drew back the curtain on a
host of unexpected toxicities of what
was thought to be the good side of
synthetic chemistry the pesticides that
pain
they're fertilizers the refrigerants and
so forth the whole better living through
chemistry package and for showing that
tremendous cost that those benefits were
paid for by she was called emotional
unscientific she was called a fear
monger all these sort of labels that
today get put on people who are critical
of biotechnology and but she really
didn't even have a part of it
some years after Rachel Carson's death
Joe and I are now part of a generation
with the lowest sperm count in history
under a depleted ozone layer and every
night my wife feeds my child
breast milk with persistent organic
pollutants in and we're the privileged
ones for communities of color and poor
communities in the shadow of chemical
facilities the attack of the synthetic
chemical industry on their lives and
their health is something more like a
slow genocide which is not to say
synthetic biology is going to be toxic
but it is to say we need to properly way
that which we do not know and we need to
take it extremely serious and it's been
discussed on this stage before it's the
Black Swan that NASA in talat talks
about or Paul Sappho's cone of
uncertainty